สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะ
กลับมาเจอกับเราสองคนในช่อง compreter
สบายดีไหมสบายดีครับวันนี้ฝนไม่ตกแล้วใช่
ไหมวันนี้ฝนไม่ตก
คิดว่าจะไม่ตกนะคะเอาล่ะครับวันนี้วัน
อะไรนะคะ
เมื่อวานตกวันนี้วันนี้ไม่ตก
พรุ่งนี้
พรุ่งนี้ไม่รู้ครับต้องรอพรุ่งนี้
พรุ่งนี้อาจจะตกนะคะอาจจะตก
วันนี้ใช่ไหม
วันนี้วันจันทร์นะคะใช่ครับวันนี้วัน
จันทร์สีเหลืองค่ะ
จันทร์ที่ 22 ครับวันนี้วันที่ 22 นะคะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนสิงหาคม
ใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับ
[เพลง]
เวลากี่โมงเวลา 6 โมง
6 โมง 5 นาทีครับ
[เพลง]
นักเรียนคะ
ถามอะไรครับ
ครูแอนตี้นี่อยู่บ้านใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับอยู่
บ้าน
อาร์ตี้ซื้อบ้าน
ซื้อบ้านคือมีเงินแล้วก็ซื้อบ้านที่
กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับซื้อบ้านที่
นนทบุรีติดกับกรุงเทพฯ
ทุกครั้ง
บางคนก็ไม่รู้ก็เรียกกรุงเทพฯเหมือนกัน
เพราะว่าติดกัน
MRT ถึงนะ
ซื้อมาประมาณ 7 ปีแล้วครับ 7 ปี
นะคะ
มีหน้าต่างมีหน้าต่างเยอะไหมคะมีหน้าต่าง
เยอะครับมีหน้าต่างหลายบานรอบๆบ้านรอบๆ
บ้านคนไทยชอบมีหน้าต่างเยอะๆเนาะเพราะ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยร้อน
[เพลง]
เปิดหน้าต่าง
แล้วเป็นยังไงคะเปิดหน้าต่างแล้ว
เปิดหน้าต่างเพื่อให้ลมครับลมเข้ามาใน
บ้าน
แต่ว่าเดี๋ยวแล้วรถติดแอร์ด้วยไหมคะ
[เพลง]
บ้านที่อยู่ใกล้ๆกันแต่ไม่ใช่บ้านเราบ้าน
ที่อยู่ใกล้ๆกันก็จะมองมองเห็นเรามองเข้า
มาทางหน้าต่างใช่ไหม
ใช่เพราะว่าบางทีบางคนผู้ชายนะคะผู้ชาย
บางคนอยู่ที่บ้านอากาศร้อนก็จะถอดเสื้อ
ไม่ใส่เสื้อใช่ไหมถอดเสื้อ
ครับถอดเสื้อออกมา
ไม่ถามครูอาร์ตี้นะคะว่าท้องไหม
อาจจะมองเห็น
มองเห็นก็ไม่เป็นส่วนตัวนะคะเวลาอยู่ใน
บ้านเราก็อยากสบายๆเพราะอากาศร้อนบางคน
ไม่ชอบเปิดแอร์นะ
คะ
ทำให้เย็นๆใช่ครับงั้นเราก็ต้องทำยังไงคะ
ติด
ผ้าใช่ไหม
ผ้าม่าน
ลงมา
ในบ้านนะไม่ได้ติดนอกบ้านนะ
ครับ
หรือว่าบางคนไม่ชอบติดผ้าม่านเปิดสว่างๆ
เพื่อนบ้านดูโอเค
ต้องติดเพราะว่าผ้าม่านเนี่ยช่วยไม่ให้
เพื่อนบ้านเห็นเราแล้วก็ช่วยป้องกันแสง
แดดด้วยมีแสงแดดเวลามีพระอาทิตย์ใช่ไหม
มีพระอาทิตย์ก็จะมีแสงแสงแดดส่องเข้ามาใน
บ้าน
เราก็จะร้อนเราก็ต้องมีผ้าม่าน
ก็เป็นผ้าม่านกันแสง
ก่อนที่จะถามครูอาร์ตี้ว่าบ้านครูอาร์ตี้
ใช้ประมาณอะไรเอ๋มีลูกนิดนึง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
แสงเพราะว่าแสงเข้ามาได้นะโปร่งแสง
เป็นม่านโปร่งแสง
บ้านโปร่งแสงก็จะบางๆเนาะใช่ครับบางๆเขา
เรียกว่ากันแสงกันแสงหน้าจะได้ประมาณสัก
35%
กันแสงได้นิดหน่อยกันแสงได้ไม่หมด
ถ้ามีแสงอยู่ที่ 100 นะคะ
100%
ผ้าม่านแบบนี้น่าจะกันนะกันแสงไม่ได้ไม่
เข้ามาเนี่ยการได้กันได้ 35% อ๋อ 35% ก็
เข้ามาได้เข้ามาได้
65%  65%
[เพลง]
เบาๆสบายๆ
โปร่งแสง
โปร่งแสงชอบไหมคะผ้าม่านโปร่งแสงชอบครับ
ชอบนะ
ส่วนต่อไปนี่ครูเอ๋มีรูปเข้ามาอันนี้ที่
บ้าน
ชอบม่านโปร่งแสงแต่ไม่ซื้ออ้าว
แล้วซื้อผ้าม่านอะไรครับซื้อผ้าม่านแบบ
นี้ค่ะประมาณ
[เพลง]
ของครูเอ๋น่าจะอยู่ที่ 7 ไม่ได้ซื้อที่
ประเทศไทยอันนี้ได้ประมาณ
70-80%
[เพลง]
UV นะคะ
60-70 ประมาณอ๋อ 60-70 นาทีล่ะครับ
เปอร์เซ็นต์
ต่อเปอร์เซ็นต์
หมายถึง
เวลาพระอาทิตย์
พระอาทิตย์สองร้อนนะคะร้อนๆตรงนี้เป็น
กระจกใช่ไหมคะ
กระจกเนี่ยถ้าร้อนมากๆเนี่ยมันจะเกิดไฟ
ได้อ่ะค่ะ
[เพลง]
ตัวนี้จะกันได้ประมาณ 60-70% นะคะเขาจะ
เขียนไว้เลยค่ะกันได้กี่เปอร์เซ็นต์
แต่ว่าบางผ้าม่านบังยี่ห้อไม่ได้บอกเรา
ต้องถามนะคะ
แล้วก็แบบนี้จะเป็นม่านจีบค่ะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
เขาสนใจกันละเอียดมากใช่ครับเป็นม่านจีบ
อันนี้มันไม่ใช่ม่านจีบ
เป็นม่านหล่อนเป็นลอนใช่ไหมใช่ไม่มีจีบ
เป็นผ้าทั้งผืนเลย
แล้วก็ตัวนี้ตัวนี้ม่าน
อะไรนะ
เป็นม่านห่วงใช่ไหมเป็นห่วงแล้วใส่เข้าไป
เขาเรียกว่าตาไก่
เป็นห่วงตาไก่โอเคคือนักเรียนนะ
ทำไมตัวนี้
กับ
ตัวนี้ไม่เหมือนกันเหรอคะ
วิธีการวิธีการติด
ตัวผ้าม่านกับกับราวผ้าม่านมันไม่เหมือน
กัน
แต่ลักษณะของพม่าเนี่ยจะเป็นลอนเหมือนกัน
ถ้าแบบแบบประมาณแบบหล่อน
แบบนี้เนี่ยเวลาเก็บอาจจะ
อาจจะ
สวยมากติดบ้างห่างบ้างไม่เป็นไร
ถ้าเป็นตาไก่ก็โอเคคล้ายๆลอนเนาะแต่ว่าจะ
เห็นจะเห็นรูตรงนี้บางคนเขาไม่ชอบเขา
ละเอียดเขาไม่ชอบ
อย่างครูเอ๋ซื้อเนี่ยครูเอ๋ไม่ได้คิดอะไร
เลยคิดแค่สีแล้วก็การความร้อนโอเคไม่มีไฟ
ไหม้เสร็จแล้วนะคะ
แล้วก็มีผ้าม่านแบบนี้ตรงนี้เห็นไหมคะตรง
นี้
เปลี่ยนเป็นสีแดง
ตรงนี้ค่ะไม่เหมือนกัน
ใช่ครับตรงที่แขวนอยู่บนราวผ้าม่านก็จะ
ไม่เหมือนกัน
คอกระเช้า
โคโยตี้เคยได้ยินเคยได้ยินเคยได้ยินเสื้อ
ที่แขวนใช่ไหม
เหมือนกับเสื้อคอกระเช้า
ก็ชอบไหมคะแบบนี้
คนที่คิดว่าแบบนี้น่าจะเลื่อนยากเลื่อน
ยากไหม
เพราะว่ามันเป็นผ้ามันเป็นใช่
อาจจะเลื่อนยากแต่ก็สวยนะครับสวย
แล้วก็อีกอันนึงเป็นผ้าม่านแบบหลุยส์
สวยมากเลย
เหมือนอยู่โรงแรมเลยครับ
แล้วก็มี
มีผ้าม่านแบบเป็นภาพผืนเดียวแต่รูดแล้ว
จะพับเป็นชั้นเป็นชั้นเป็นชั้นขึ้นไป
แบบนี้ก็สวยนะ
เก็บไป
หมุนเก็บลงไปแบบนี้แบบม้วนนะคะ
แต่จะมีคล้ายๆแบบนี้อีกอย่างหนึ่งที่
คล้ายๆพลาสติกอ่ะก็คือเอาลงมาแล้วดึงปุ๊บ
ก็เก็บเข้าไปเลย
อ๋อ
คุณเอก็ไม่รู้อันนั้นอะไรนะคะ
แล้วก็ตัวนี้
ตัวนี้เลขอะไรครูเอ๋จำชื่อไม่ได้นะอันนี้
ก็ม้วนขึ้นไปไหมครับม้วนเหมือนกันค่ะ
ก็จะมีม้วนแต่ว่าตัวนี้ไม่ใช่ผ้า
แต่เป็นม่านที่แบบมีรูเล็กๆ
ที่ทำให้มองเห็นวิวได้
มองเห็นวิวแล้วก็กันแสงแล้วก็
เอาลงมาเป็นแผ่นเลยค่ะ
ลงมาเป็นแผ่นแบบนี้เขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
หมายถึงชื่อชื่อของผ้าม่านเหรอครับ
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าลงมาเป็นเป็นผืนใหญ่เลยใช่ไหมใช่
ค่ะ
เป็นผืนใหญ่คนที่อยู่คอนโดน่าจะชอบ
แต่บางคนเขาก็จะมีผ้าตัวนี้อีกอันนึง
2 ชั้นใช่ไหม
ไม่ไว้ปิด
ปรับแสงเยอะๆเวลาที่ไม่อยากให้แสงเข้า
แล้วก็มีอีกเนาะ
อ่าอันนี้ก็เป็นผ้าม่านเป็นชั้นๆนะคะ
ก็คือถ้าเราจะเอามาชั้นสีขาวอันเดียวก็
เห็นวิวข้างนอกแต่ถ้าเกิดเราปิดทั้งหมด
ทุกชั้นก็ 1 ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3 ชั้นก็จะไม่
ต้องเห็นวิวก็ได้เพิ่มเพิ่มความเค็มได้
แล้วก็อันนี้เป็นฟิล์ม
ติดฟิล์มไปเลย
อันนี้ก็ไม่ต้องปิดเปิดผ้าม่านแล้วถ้าติด
ฟิล์มเพราะว่าติดฟิล์มก็เอ่อปิดเปิดไม่
ได้ต้องติดอยู่กับกระจกเลย
แสงก็ไม่เข้าเหมือนกันแต่มองเห็นวิว
อันนี้ค่ะ
มู่ลี่ไม้อ๋อทำมาจากไม้ใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่
แล้วก็ตัวนี้อะไรนะ
ม่านปรับแสงอ๋อเป็นม่านปรับแสงตัวนี้ก็
คล้ายๆกับมู่ลี่ไหม
คล้ายๆบูลลี่
[เพลง]
เป็นอลูมิเนียมแล้วก็หมุนปรับปิดเปิดได้
ปิดแล้วก็เปิดให้แสงเข้าได้
อยากได้ความสว่างเท่าไรก็จะมี 2 แบบเนาะ
แบบนี้ด้วยนะคะ
ทีนี้เนี่ยตอนนี้เราเอาแค่แบบก่อนนะคะยัง
ไม่เลือกผ้าเอาแค่แบบก่อนครูอาร์ตี้
เวลาที่ครูอาร์ตี้จะ
จะ
เลือกผ้าม่าน
เรามีบ้านครูอาร์ตี้อยู่ตรงนี้ครูเอกวาด
ให้
ได้ครับว่าเฉพาะบ้านหรือว่าเฉพาะหน้าต่าง
จะได้เห็นประมาณชัดๆ
บ้าน 2 ชั้น
หน้าต่างชั้นที่ 2
ประตูหน้าต่างใหญ่มากหน้าต่างครูอาร์ตี้
ใหญ่หรือเล็กคะหน้าต่างมีทั้งใหญ่และเล็ก
ครับแต่ว่าก็เอาเป็นหน้าต่างเล็กก็ได้
ครับจะได้ง่ายๆ
อันเดียวพอ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ตอนครูอาร์ตี้จะเลือกผ้าม่านเนี่ย
เอาตัวครูอาร์ตี้ก่อน
เลือกลายผ้าม่านก่อน
[เพลง]
เลย
เอาแบบไหนดี
แบบไหนดีใช่ไหมโอเคก็เลือกด้วยครับแต่
เป็นเลือกพร้อมๆกันที่ร้านเวลาเราเลือก
ลายเสร็จเขาก็จะถามว่าจะเอาแบบไหนดีแบบ
ห่วงตาไก่เอาแบบจีบแบบเราก็บอกเขาได้ใช่
ครับ
[เพลง]
ไม่ได้เลือกแบบอะไรนะคะไม่ได้เลือกแบบนี้
อ๋อใช่ๆขวดที่เลือกผ้าม่านไม่ได้เลือก
มู่ลี่ไม่ได้เลือก
ปรับแสงห้ามปรับแสงใช่ใช่ครับเรียกเป็น
ผ้าม่านเลยใช่เลือกเป็นพม่าเลย
แล้วพอไปปั๊บเนี่ยเขาคือแล้วรู้จักร้าน
ผ้าม่านได้ยังไงอ่ะ
มีร้านผ้าม่านอยู่ที่ไหนบ้างแล้วที่ร้าน
นี้มีผ้าม่านแบบไหนให้เลือกนะครับ
แล้วค่อยไปที่ร้าน
ใช่ครับ
ต้องโทรศัพท์นัดว่าวันนี้เปิดไหมเปิดกี่
โมงถึงกี่โมงเดี๋ยวโคโยตี้จะเข้าไปตอนกี่
โมง 2 โมงเข้าไปอะไรอย่างนี้ครับ
เขาก็จะเอาเขาก็จะถามก่อนถามว่ากลัวตี้
ก่อนว่าจะเอาผ้าม่านเนี่ยไปแบบที่ต้องการ
ต้องการแบบไหนแบบกันแสงด้วยไหมแบบที่
ทึบแสงคือปิดไม่ให้เห็นอะไรเลยเอาแบบไหน
เส้นแสงก็ประมาณนี้สีเข้มๆแบบ
ผ้าอย่างของครูเอ๋ตัวนี้นี่ไม่ร้อย
เปอร์เซ็นต์
แสงเข้าได้นะคะถ้าตัวนี้ก็โปร่งแสง
ตัวนี้ก็
80%
ชอบแบบไหนคะ
ใสๆแบบนี้ 1 ชั้นแล้วก็มีชั้นทึบแสงอีก 1
ชั้นเป็น 2 ชั้น
อ๋อไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรก็คือมีแบบนี้อยู่
ชั้นนึงแบบใสๆโปร่งเพราะบางวันกลัวติ๊กก็
อยากจะให้แสงแสงเข้ามาในบ้านด้วยก็เปิด
ปิดชั้นทึบแล้วก็เปิดเฉพาะชั้นที่เป็นใสๆ
แบบนี้โปร่งแสงแบบนี้
อยู่ด้านนอก
ไม่มีเอามาโปร่งแสงด้านในทุกแสงด้านนอกนะ
เอาแบบไหนอ่ะต้องเอาโปร่งแสงอยู่ด้านนอก
แล้วก็ทึบแสงอยู่ด้านที่อยู่ในบ้านที่เรา
เห็นเพราะเวลาปิดรับแสงก็จะไม่เข้ามา
[เพลง]
ใช่ครับ
กลัวความร้อนเข้ามาเจอแล้วไฟไหม้ตัวโปร่ง
แสงเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่จะเป็นผ้าไม้ผ้าลินินก็
ผ้าซิ่น
ผ้าบางๆโอกาสที่จะเจอความร้อน
เขาควรจะเอาโปร่งแสงไว้ข้างในหรือว่า
โปร่งแสงไว้ข้างนอก
ผมคิดว่าน่าจะเอาโปร่งแสงไว้ข้างในทั้ง
หมดนะครับ
ปกติจากโรงแรมที่โรงแรมก็จะมีผ้าม่าน 2
ชั้นเหมือนกัน
ก็จะมีชั้นที่เป็นชั้นที่
โปร่งแสงอยู่ข้างในและข้างด้านในห้องก็จะ
เป็นด้านทึบแสง
ใช่เนาะ
แทนที่ 22 ใส่เพราะว่าเอ๋เห็นบ้านเพื่อน
บ้านเพื่อนที่
ที่ต่างประเทศนะคะเขาจะเอาทึบแสงและด้าน
นอก
โปร่งแสงด้านในเพราะว่าตัวทึบแสงด้านหลัง
ของทึบแสงเนี่ยเขาตัวนี้ค่ะ
ตัวนี้เนี่ยตรงนี้เขาจะกัน UV เนาะเวลามี
แสงมาก็สะท้อนออก
แล้วสะท้อนออกแล้วก็จะมีอีกราวนึงที่เป็น
โปร่งแสงอยู่ด้านในด้านในเวลาที่เขาอะไร
นะเขาใช้นะเขาก็จะ
เปิดตัวโปร่งแสงใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ค่อย
ดึงตัวทึบแสงปิดเวลาจะนอนเวลาตื่นเช้าเขา
ก็เปิดตัวทึบแสงแล้วก็ดึงโปร่งแสงออกมา
ไม่รู้ว่าแบบไหนดีกว่าแต่ที่ประเทศไทย
ส่วนมากคือโปร่งแสงอยู่ด้านนอกใช่ไหมคะ
ด้านนอก
แค่อยากรู้ว่ามันต่างกันยังไง
เพราะปกติเวลาครัวที่เปิดบ้านก็จะเปิด
เฉพาะตัวทึบแสงอย่างเดียวโปร่งแสงก็จะ
อยู่ที่เดิมไม่ต้องทำอะไรอ๋อไม่ต้องเปิด
แล้วใช่เพราะมันอยู่ด้านนอกอยู่แล้วมันก็
เปิดบันทึกอย่างเดียวจบใช่ครับ
อาจจะขึ้นอยู่กับมุมของของกระจก
ขึ้นอยู่กับการใช้งานด้วยครับว่าอยากจะ
ให้ห้องมืดปกติชอบห้องมืดมากกว่าหรือชอบ
ห้องโปร่งแสงมากกว่าถ้าชอบห้องโปร่งแสง
มากกว่าก็เอาทึบแสงไว้ข้างในแล้วเราก็
เปิดแค่ทึบห้องก็โปร่ง
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าไม่ GM บอกว่าอาจจะขึ้นอยู่กับ
มุมของห้องที่รับแสงเยอะขนาดไหน
ถ้ามุมห้องที่รับแสงนานๆก็น่าจะเอาทึบแสง
ไว้ด้านนอก
วันนี้เราก็รู้แล้วว่าบ้านครูอาร์ตี้
เนี่ยก็คือมีทั้งม่านโปร่งแสงแล้วประมาณ
ทริปแสงใช่
เขาให้เลือกผ้าม่านกลัวแอนตี้เลือกผ้าแบบ
ไหนค่ะ
ผ้าแบบไหนใช่ไหมครับกลัวที่จำไม่ได้แล้ว
ว่ามันชื่ออะไรแต่ว่ากลัวที่รู้ว่าภาพ
เป็นภาพแบบที่หนาๆหนาๆแล้วก็มี
LINE  LINE ที่ควรตี้ชอบเป็นลายดอกไม้นะ
ครับ
เป็นผ้าหนาแล้วมีลายใช่ๆเป็นผ้าหนาแล้วก็
มีลาย
ถ้ามีลาย
ก็มันจะมีผ้าอยู่ 2 อย่างคือผ้าคอตตอน
หรือลินินเลยนะคะกับผ้าถ้าเป็นผ้าของครู
เอ๋เนี่ยมันจะเป็นคล้ายๆโพลีเอสเตอร์
อันนี้บ้านครูเอก็จะเป็นซีเรียสคือ
ใส่ลายไม่ได้นะคะแต่เขาจะมีแบบ
polyester ผสมกับผ้าฝ้ายหรือผสม
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าจะคล้ายๆผ้าจริงๆ
อ๋อแต่มีลายด้วยนะคะใช่ครับมีลายด้วย
แต่บางคนชอบเป็นผ้าเลย
น่าจะผสมโพลีเอสเตอร์ไหมหรือว่าเป็นภาพ
ที่กลัวที่คิดว่าน่าจะผสมครับน่าจะผสมมา
ด้วยเป็น
โพลิเอสเตอร์กับอาจจะเป็น Cotton หรือ
เป็นผ้าฝ้ายนะครับ
เพราะว่ามันนุ่มๆแล้วก็ฟูๆใช่แล้วก็หนาๆ
นิดนึงว่าต้องทึบแสงครับ
มีฝุ่นเกาะมากไหมคะ
น่าจะผสมค่ะ
ซักไม่ได้
ของครัว
เอ๋ก็คือเป็นแบบผสมนะคะ
ผสมก็ซักได้นะคะ
โอเควันนี้เราก็รู้แล้วนะคะว่าบ้านครู
อาร์ตี้เดี๋ยวยังไม่จบสิมีอะไรอีกครับ
เลือกลายแล้วอ่ะแล้ว
แล้วจะรู้ขนาดได้ยังไงคะ
ปฏิวัติเองหรอคะอ้าววัดเองครับ
[เพลง]
ว่าหน้าต่างกว้างเท่านี้ยาวเท่านี้แล้ว
เขาก็จะทำการคำนวณว่าต้องใช้ผ้าม่านขนาด
เท่าไหร่กี่เมตรกี่เมตร
[เพลง]
เอาไปด้วยเอาไปวัดแต่ถ้าเกิดว่าอย่างเอ๋
ถ้าเกิดว่าใช้ตลาดใช้ไม่มีตลับเมตร
[เพลง]
ได้เหมือนกันครับได้เหมือนกันสายวัดขนาด
นี้วัดได้ไหมคะ
วัดได้ครับแต่ต้องวัดหลายรอบครับวัดต่อ
กันไป 1  2
มาต่อกันไปหลายๆครั้ง
เราต้องจับดีๆนะคะเขาจะงอขึ้นมาปุ๊บ
ขนาดก็จะไม่เท่ากัน
อะไรนะความกว้างความกว้างของหน้าตานะครับ
ความสูงของหน้าต่างด้วย
แล้วเราก็ไปบอกที่ร้าน
หรือให้ทางร้าน
ที่บ้านได้เหมือนกันใช่แต่ถ้าร้านมาวัด
ที่บ้านก็จะ
แพงขึ้นอ๋อนิดหน่อยแพงขึ้นนิดหน่อยนะครับ
[เพลง]
มารปรับแสงหรือชอบแบบใหม่คือลงมาแล้วมอง
เห็นวิวไม่ใช่มากก็ได้นะคะ
โอเค
หมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมหมดเวลาแล้วครับเดี๋ยว
คราวหน้าเรามาเจอกันใหม่ครับมาเจอกับ
ครัวตี้กับครูเอ๋ได้ใหม่ในช่อง
complainbow ไทยนะครับเดี๋ยวค่อยติดตาม
กันวันนี้เราสองคนต้องลาไปก่อนล่ะครับ
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนบ๊ายบาย